[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
remember back in early 2017 a trailer
was released to mark the beginning of a
new game codenamed
the avengers project said to be revealed
at a later date well I know you're
already aware that it happened at e3 and
I'm a mixture of excited and a little
wary so let's break down the top 20
things you should know about the
Avengers project which is now officially
named Marvel's Avengers and if you are a
PlayStation gamer things are looking
mighty good for us
[Music]
let's start with understanding what the
heck is the game genre the official
blurb states a multi-year multi
partnership action-adventure title but
how does that break down well
interestingly marvel's avengers will be
both a single player and a four-player
cooperative game I don't know about you
but when I hear those words I pick -
destiny or dare I say it and thumb
springs to mind the problem is we
haven't been given any further
information to make our assumptions
towards so we need to keep our mind open
on marvel's avengers so i did a little
digging and cast my mind back to the
Marvel heroes MMO do you remember it it
was a free to play game with
microtransactions designed to make money
we'll get back to the microtransactions
part soon but the thing i want to
concentrate on here is that Marvel
heroes was closed down less than five
months after the console version
released this could just be a
coincidence and Marvel taking back their
licenses or this could be making space
for Marvel's Avengers to fill that mm o
void and here's why I believe that
Marvel's Avengers will be a live game
it's confirmed a game as a service in
which future content will continuously
release for years to come
oh yes Marvel's Avengers doesn't want to
be a one playthrough wonder it wants us
to keep coming back for every single
update and edition I've got to admit I'm
on board with that but what about you
the core mechanic in Marvel's Avengers
is the ability to choose your character
at present we've seen the five main
Avengers you think of from the film
universe Tony Stark for Black Widow Hulk
and good old cap himself yeah there's no
Hawkeye
sorry bro
we'll be able to choose a hero to play
their way behind closed doors gameplay
reveal gave more details and believe me
it should have been part of the
public-facing show because III 2019 had
little to no gameplay anywhere each
character plays massively different from
one another
for example Hulk beating the living hell
out of enemies with pure physical force
is miles away from the speed and finesse
that Black Widow offers with her
acrobatics and twin pistols and those
spy gadgets - I see this as a huge
advantage of the game because I don't
know about you but I get a little bored
at playing as the same character
constantly variety will keep Marvel's
Avengers fresh by the way in the demo
the slow-motion moments felt like
watching a movie in which we are the
Avengers a truly cinematic experience I
mean who doesn't want to throw cap
shield around like a complete badass the
multiplayer portion allows for squad
mates to take a different member of the
Avengers and combine their efforts so he
can't have poor falls it's unclear if
all missions support team play but once
again using the press release we can
confirm the world is filled with single
and co-op missions but what does that
really mean how do you see that I like
to play alone and they confirmed that
majority of things can be played all on
your tot so no one will be stealing your
thunder anyway let's take a step back
and look at the story here's something
which has been pushed heavily it's not
the same universe as the movies get that
out of your head this is a
brand-spanking-new story
and although it will use the history
scene in the comic books it will be a
standalone project for example the game
picks up with the Avengers unveiling
their dope new headquarters in San
Francisco only father shooter hit the
fan and the Helicarrier is sabotage
resulting in the death of many innocent
people lovely start The Avengers are
blamed disbanded and outlawed five years
later the worlds in peril again the only
hope is to reassemble Earth's Mightiest
Heroes do the Avengers pose a danger to
society that was the question Bruce that
was the question now's the time to talk
about exclusive content and expansions
and all the money hungry tactics we
worry about as gamers Marvel's Avengers
will continue to add new superheroes and
locations of regions to the game for
example Hank Pym you know good old og
ant-man looks to be introduced as a
future update shrinking powers and
possibly enlarging ones too would make
up his core skill set but here's the
biggest takeaway if you own the base
game every single one of these updates
will be absolutely free no additional
costs at all so hypothetically you could
play the core story on the day the game
releases take a few days or a few years
off and once you return everything that
you've missed in that time all the new
releases will be there waiting for you
know season pass
you know expansion costs not everyone
has the money to buy everything a game
releases we can't get all those BOTS
Knight skins
for example so let's cherish this moment
things are even better for PlayStation 4
gamers thanks to a partnership between
Sony and Marvel the same partnership
that allowed spider-man to return to the
MCU and the same partnership which made
the fantastic Marvel's spider-man on the
ps4 legit one of the greatest superhero
games ever made but before I get
sidetracked on that back to Marvel's
Avengers the ps4 partnership and the PS
5 - I suppose we'll first see the beta
released on PlayStation before other
platforms but then it gets sort of
ambiguous officially there will be
exclusive bonuses which will be revealed
at a later date so I looked into
previous Sony partnerships with games
like destiny - bot Knight Red Dead
online and many others these
partnerships are focused around four key
possibilities exclusive skins own armor
brilliant exclusive weapon skills and
abilities bloody great exclusive maps
and new areas freaking awesome and early
content drops marvellous so even at this
early stage if you're a PlayStation
gamer your experience should be that
little bit more immersive and rewarding
than other platforms when there's more
details I'll let you know but I'm really
interested to know your opinions on
exclusive content I find that I like it
when it's for the PlayStation but hate
it on it's not on PlayStation so what
say you okay
so the elephant in the room monetization
if content is free was the catch it has
to be Mycroft transactions right yep I
agree I agree but first hear this
statement from Square Enix although
everything will be delivered over years
there will never be random loot boxes or
pay2win scenarios let that sink in of
course there are other ways to make
money satisfy your audience off I'll cut
their throat in some examples let's use
destiny - again because level capping
season passes throttling experience and
pushing the star in your face constantly
has proven that goodwill will be taken
advantage of
how could Marvel's Avengers do this
without taking advantage the fortnight
method has been advantageous a shopfront
selling cosmetic items think about the
amount of costumes your favorite
superhero has gone through over the
comic years
in the movies alone Captain America has
around 63 outfits if I'm not mistaken
but in our seriousness we could buy our
favorite outfits look at spider-man on
the ps4 and how happy the fan base was
to see Sam Raimi's spider-man costume
added personally I want Peter Parker's
Fantastic Four suit look at that
handcrafted mask sweet loot indeed and
yeah honestly I'd probably pay $10 for
that so I'm a little bit of a spider-man
fanboy and by no means has Peter been
confirmed to be in Marvel's Avengers but
here's a thought
as Sony are in charge of the spider-man
license and are actively working with
Marvel would it be possible to see a
crossover between Marvel's Avengers and
Marvel spider-man on ps4 the crossover
mission may be a cameo are most likely
the PlayStation 4 spider-man suit will
make it into the game man that game was
good I'm gonna go back and play after
this video let's rain this back in
though and look at something else
confirmed in Marvel's Avengers
customization we will build our Avengers
in sort of like an RPG role-playing game
way each character will level up and
gain abilities through archetypal skill
trees as we've mastered their powers
it's likely Kia score will play a part
too and like we've already mentioned
looking good is the main reason we
customized a pink Hulk anyone okay just
me in terms of villains we've seen -
thus far taskmaster and abomination and
know he doesn't get a lot of love but I
really like the taskmaster his core
skill is photogenic reflexes basically
if he sees something he can instantly do
it pretty cool and he's also got the
good old superhuman speed and all that
jazz abomination on the other hand I
don't know too much about I've always
felt like he's an evil Hulk but I need
more information on that can someone
tell me something about abomination I'll
be in the comments looking for details I
need to learn but while we're talking
about villains it's important to note
that more are coming each update will
bring in new storylines and introduce
more enemies to face with different
skill sets and weaknesses once again
keeping the game feeling fresh for years
to come and finally when do we get our
hands on this not long at all
may 15th 2020 with a beta coming to
Marvel's Avengers is available on ps4 PC
Xbox one Andy
the stadia that's the first time I've
ever said stadia out loud I guess I get
used to it I'll be playing on
PlayStation with those added extras
let's get your opinions in the comments
about everything we've gone through in
the video exclusive content free updates
what's on your mind I'll be looking for
your comments to find things to ask the
devs at a later date I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]